these roads are some of the most
dangerous in europe
when winter strikes transport routes
traveled by 50 ton trucks
turn into bobsleigh tracks
and when the major commercial highways
aren't highways at all
but winding mountain roads
it's a recipe for disaster
but throughout norway there's a brigade
of rescue workers
it takes a special breed of men to keep
the roads open
[Music]
[Music]
i hate this bus in this episode of ice
road rescue it can be
maybe a big explode
you get this wire in your head they're
completely dead
[Music]
here in the southern mountains of norway
it's an unseasonably mild start to the
winter
[Music]
today today very quiet a little bit work
we have but it's
too quiet
tord paulson is the boss of a six
million euro rescue and repair business
carrying his name his headquarters is in
norway's southern mountains
while snow means chaos and accidents to
some
tord makes his living off it money
coming down from the
sky
[Music]
but no snow also means no money
few vehicles in distress means too much
idleness for the crew
[Music]
tord takes matters into his own hands
[Music]
yes then we are going to drive a little
trip
and see if we can see some trucks have
problem on the road
uh if we don't find we make something
come here and we hear that if we not go
out maybe there is a truck stay uh
problem on the road so we think it's
good business for us to do it like this
up ahead there seems to be a car having
difficulties
hardly a big job but work his work
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this was my mother she is more crazy
than i ever have been so they say
everything
[Music]
around 600 kilometers up north of thord
winter has arrived and is claiming its
first victims
this is my first accident in my life and
in norway it's
a tractor semi-trailer lost control
skidded
and toppled over its polish driver is
unhurt
but visibly shaken i think maybe i died
i don't know i
driving and one moment
i have accidents the fire department is
first to the scene
yeah it's okay
the fire department determines there's
no fire hazard here
the truck is carrying only empty pallets
so the road rescue team can begin work
but immediately there's a problem
the truck has tipped into a small river
the ground underneath is so uneven
it's going to make this a very tricky
job
[Music]
oh jesus
meanwhile the police are on the spot to
regulate the traffic
it may be only a two-lane road but it's
a major commercial route
it can be very dangerous we have another
truck passing and you can go
but yeah the time is not on our side so
after an hour marius arrives and the
work can begin
on this job marius will be the one in
charge
his specific skills and his tools will
be needed for this tricky job
you gotta use some uh big airbags to
lift
the trailer up my specialty is topping
big trucks
and using these airbags
if it's a big operation we have to use
the airbags i will be the boss
can you put in the iron back in the back
and in the front
i take the this truck in the front and
they use the airbags
and then they pull the whole [ __ ] on the
rope
we're gonna use four we have if you have
five but i'm gonna use four here
because of the three staying in the
middle
using four airbags the plan is to raise
the truck to a point where they can wrap
straps around it
attach cables and then pull it back up
onto its wheels
traffic is beginning to pile up and will
only get worse
this could take a while the semi
presenting a more complex problem than
first anticipated
very hard to get the airbags under there
because the river was
quite deep yeah this is a complicated
operation
because of the slope from the kitchen up
the road
it's very difficult it's heavy loaded
and
as many things can't go wrong the
airbags can explode and
go to the ditcher and the trailer can
collapse and it's many things
we have to think of everything here
we'll try to lift it so much we can and
then we
take the trucks and we pull it up the
road
so i think maybe two hours
this operation
down south tord is out on the road
looking for jobs
believe it or not this is one of the
major east-west commercial routes in the
country
and now the snow is finally starting to
fly
let's see it's a little bit cold today
this is very
bad that's worse it is that's better it
is for me
i like stress i like working quick and i
like when everything go like
without problems some are straight
forward like this
bus which is stuck on the hill but now
it's sheer number of jobs that is an
issue for toured
maybe 20 cars i take up one bus
two trucks it's crazy
so today i little bit stressed but now i
have to relax because
it's not my heart stop because everybody
calling help help help
even more snow is expected so todd needs
reinforcements
he calls in olaf his right hand man for
what promises to be
a busy night this is my life
when i not walk i drink and have fun
oh love is a very good man i can
call him when i want because he don't
have woman
[Music]
i was a party yesterday but i cannot
drive early
i am late sleeper i think nine years now
i'm
working with the trucks that's a funny
business
olav needs to get to toured fast the
jobs are piling up some
are even returned business it's the
third time i helped this person today so
the first thing he said for me today you
get richer on the bus he said for me but
that's correct
very bad problem to connecting the
wiring for this [ __ ] i hope i can finish
this work because uh
i think these men have to go to the
station with the people they've been
with him
maybe five six hour this day
i hate this bus
in the north marius is under the gun to
get the truck upright
in the south olav is heading out to help
tord
just like that towards getting more work
than he can handle
it's gone from business famine to feast
it's the third time he's had to pull
this same bus out of a snow bank
finally he and olaf can head out to
scout
for bigger jobs
i go scouting because if you don't do it
maybe the
competition get the work in the road
rescue business
it's first come first served todd needs
to hustle
and stay proactive i know we hope
maybe somebody of this get problem to a
person
this being a main commercial route the
chances of stumbling across
trucks in trouble are good
yes
now we get little bit more work i hope
hello
your problem the train cabot it's a
turkish truck
on its way to bergen it's been driving
without
tire chains not a good idea on roads
like these
you want new no no no no you want you
want help
you want help okay
so but you see this fire this is [ __ ]
this is
turns out the truck is not just missing
chains
even the tires themselves are wrong
they're summer ones
it makes driving through these mountains
downright dangerous
these people are crazy look for this
fire they have
it's crazy it's uh not not good for
driving in norway
because it's dangerous to start to go
down you know it's uh
it's not good this man is very lucky you
know
if he may be driving a little bit longer
up and
if the truck stops he finished
the truck is on its way to pick up cargo
so it's empty
and light making it even riskier to
drive in these conditions
i really don't know what to do now
because it's
it's not good for me to call the police
because this man have problems or maybe
i give him
more problem uh we have to do something
maybe if i let him go from here you know
maybe he go over the mountain and he
crashed somebody
then i don't feel good you know so they
have to call the police
sword makes the call and then tows the
truck to the rendezvous point with the
police
immediately the police removed the
plates
in norway it's against the law for
trucks to drive on the wrong tires
i think maybe this man maybe stay here
maybe two weeks before he can go from
here because maybe he need new tires
maybe he need all new chains so maybe he
call home you know so maybe somebody
coming with jane
i don't know i think maybe he's the stay
here for a long time
[Applause]
so today we have good morning now we are
happy no way everybody can smile because
now we got a lot of money for this
school
[Music]
back up north marius is working to get
the truck upright and out of the water
a job that was supposed to take two
hours is now
already into our four
the three small airbags are positioned
on the sides
the last and biggest bag in the middle
the airbags are starting to inflate it's
a critical moment
the police again need to close the road
with traffic building in both directions
the ticking of the clock is getting that
much louder
[Music]
it's very slippery and the bags can come
out
then you're gonna shoot yourself
there's a problem
as the team inflates the biggest bag it
slides sideways
marius has to start all over again
meanwhile the traffic cues are getting
longer and longer
so we have to do this operation like the
whole trailer
took a little too long i think
[Music]
for their second try they move the
smaller bags out to the corners
hoping to create more stable ground for
the big bag in the middle
the side the trailer is resting on is
beginning to bulge
making it even harder to get the bags
into position
you get the airbags under and you see
the trailer is damaged it's gonna
so uh we're gonna try a little bit more
but if you don't do the
naked you have to empty the whole
trailer by hand
[Music]
having a successful day up north marius
is having his difficulties
he's now been at it for five hours and
due to the traffic
the police are getting impatient marius
is now worried they'll have to empty out
the trailer by hand
this may be good for marius's bottom
line but
for the polish driver it's all very
upsetting
i don't know how long the people take
the truck to the road the trail is
damaged
and it's very
all difficult wait i got
the rescuers are going to give it one
more shot using the airbags
they really don't want to have to
offload the cargo if they can help it
still marius is unhappy with the
position of the airbags
the trailer needs to be absolutely
stable
in order to get the straps underneath
taking this down the furthest the guys
have to work
under the trailer to help create more
space for the airbags
this is risky considering the bulging
cargo hold
certainly maybe the trailer can be
damaged and the whole
cargo is coming out it's very dangerous
down in the southern mountains a few
kilometers away from toured
there's another rescue business this one
run by just
one man a lone wolf and local legend
his name is bjorn
[Music]
this is a man's place that is
my working place no one else bjorn
legreed is the grand old man of these
mountains
and he's one of the most experienced tow
rescuers in the area
be honest my car brothers you're more
crazy the work is
that's better me and bjorn like it this
is the oldest
truck that i have the best car
bjorn has just received a call a truck
has driven off the road in the hardanga
mountains
and there's a major winter storm brewing
six o'clock
it's gonna be 10 meter per second
seven o'clock 12 8 o'clock 18
18 meter per second no good weather
you have to see what you're doing and if
you don't see
because of the wind and the snow you
can't do anything that's
very simple a double tractor trailer
when skidding off the road
its back trailer twisting and falling on
its side
the mountain is a dangerous place when a
storm hits
but bjorn is determined to come to this
driver's aid
arriving on the scene bjorn assesses the
situation
i won't say anything before i have seen
it on the other side
well we have to go out and talk with her
hi hi when i was first come and see the
track guys it or
think about themselves this one's not
going to be easy
the driver is norwegian in these
mountains even experienced
local truckers can get ambushed by the
conditions
it was my first time it had to come
diern soon realizes this job is too big
even for him
with a storm headed in their direction
he's in a hurry
there's only one man he can trust
just have to call phone to toured
bjorn called me and there is a truck and
a trailer so go out of the
road and he tell me that we have a lot
of work up there
so so now we are going up there and see
what we can do
working with tord is no problem he has
been doing this for four years
i've been doing this for about 17 18
years
so i trying to learn him something and
maybe something sometimes he see
things that i don't see the truck is
loaded with delicate building materials
glass and light wooden frames it needs
to be handled with care
the first thing is it's a heavy thing
normally they're loaded
when you begin you have to use a few
minutes extra to see
not just take a wire here and wire there
and try to cool
then you can break a lot of things
that's very expensive
up north marius is still working on
getting the truck
up on its wheels this is the last
attempt
if it doesn't work they'll have to empty
the entire trailer
by hand
finally marius is satisfied with the
position of the airbags
the crew can connect the wires and start
pulling the trailer upright
yeah getting some chainsaw
and we're getting ready to plant off
this
tow trucks and we're gonna use the
airbags to get it over
and we're gonna hold it to the trucks
and pull it off the road
first they're going to wrap recovery
straps around the trailer
then with the right balance of tension
between the airbags and the wires
connected to the straps
they'll tilt it upright hopefully
without further damage to the truck
or its contents
when the airbags are filled the wires
connected to the truck will
tighten with the trucks heavy weight
the tension distribution is crucial yeah
so far so good
it's gonna be easier and easier
at this point they've raised the truck
just enough to get a second strap around
the trailer we're gonna put on these
traps
under the trailer if an airbag or a wire
snaps now
it could crush somebody
foreign
the airbags are finally fully inflated
now it's all up to the ropes around the
trailer
to tilt it back onto its wheels
[Music]
while todd and bjorn are figuring out
how to approach their problem
marius and his crew are now on their
sixth hour
and the traffic cues are stretching out
in each direction
everyone is losing patience
[Music]
however the risks are far from over the
truck may now be up on its wheels but
the job is only half done
they now need to pull it out of the
watery ditch
marius is pushing the machine to its max
but the truck
simply won't budge
another angle to try to lift it up
the wire is screaming and could snap at
any moment
under time pressure it's easy to
overlook the obvious
another check of the truck reveals that
the brakes are still
on that's simple oversight fixed
and they're ready for another go
so
while marius is fighting against time
and traffic
down south bjorn and toad are about to
fight
an even tougher foe mother nature
an immense winter storm has them right
in its crosshairs
the plan is now that we are going to
tillanga off the track
and then we want to take the truck on
the
road the plan is to disconnect the back
trailer from the front trailer
and then winch them up on the road one
by one
we start the work and we hope everything
go good
oh funny the problem is that when the
back trailer flipped
the coupling got twisted there is a
little bit problem to
take them
still some jobs are just a matter of
elbow grease
and a hammer this trailer must be
disconnected manually
and to disconnect it they decide to pull
the front trailer with wires
to get a better angle
[Music]
i know we try to move a little bit on it
so we get the
till hangout
then it's off so now the the
trailer is free so so no way uh
it's everything is better it's now been
several hours
finally the real work can begin
the storm is building time is short
we try to find a good place where we can
take the wiring so to take it on the
road
but there is not so good places if we
were attached the
wire at the wrong place then maybe the
whole trailer would
tip off and then we have a big big
bad situation
the delicate cargo has a total value of
about
two hundred thousand euros todd and
bjorn
have to be careful not only trying to
save the truck
but hopefully without damaging the
contents can be
maybe a big explode
it can happen that the one of the
belt for the truck maybe explode so it's
like you shoot somebody maybe a little
bit higher the air bellows
for the the truck is very dangerous when
we're towing
the truck sidewise or something this can
explode
and it's a very big sound when this
explodes
in the southern mountains the storm is
closing in
bjorn and tord have to hurry to get the
trailer up
before it gets buried in snow
besides running the risk of cracking the
bellows of the air brakes
the guys also need to consider the
strength of the wires
always it's a something can happen you
know maybe one wire
can cut off because maybe there is stone
or something you don't know
maybe some parts from the trailer maybe
from the truck and only
and then you get it maybe in head you
can kill yourself
we have to take it forward now when he
has connect then
they put special iron grids in front of
the wheels to give the truck
extra traction
but still the weight is enormous
bjorn's towing truck starts to slip
there is a danger that it could tip over
whilst bjorn and tord are racing to the
storm marius is now into his eighth hour
on this job
everyone's exhausted
still they have to be extra cautious
especially since the attachment broke
trailer snaps off under a pool
and that is very very dangerous
if you get this wire in your head they
are completely dead
the traffic is still piling up in both
directions
they have to solve this fast but stay
[Music]
smart
[Music]
the tow truck can full 45 tons but they
have to figure out a plan
so it doesn't slide while it's pulling
after giving it a think
marius comes up with a plan he'll use
what the landscape gives
him my truck doesn't doesn't stand on
the road
i have to attach him in a tree
on the other side of the road
with a cable attached to the tree
hopefully
they'll prevent the tow truck from
sliding
[Music]
the trailer is already damaged
the only focus now is to get it back on
the road as quickly as possible
the crew are fighting both time and the
weight
the road has to open and the only way to
do that
is to get this truck out of the way
[Music]
then you were able to pull the truck up
on the road again
place it uh in the side of the road here
and they're gonna take the traffic and
then you're gonna pack it all together
[Music]
finally the truck is back on the road a
nine-hour job has come to an end
and the police can open the road again a
tired crew can finally
[Music]
you're tired and relax
you're gonna inject the the trailer from
the truck
you're gonna hitch off the trailer on
this truck and you're gonna drive it to
troll
the truck is on the road ready to get
towed away
but down south things are getting tense
it's not just the job toward and burn
are also going to have to fight the
elements
[Music]
unlike the truck up north this one seems
to be in a good shape
the successful rescue is putting the
guys in a good mood
you know in winter you see we use this
for trucks
and in summer we use it for greeley at
beyonce's place
we grill with it you know fire right
there and food up
this is special the secret we have in
norway
we grill with it with the summer
but the good mood is short-lived on
closer inspection they discover there
actually is
damage to the truck when we uh
get the the truck on the road
we see the excel was off
the guys have to fix the broken axle so
that the truck can make it down from the
mountain
but now the heart of the storm is just
minutes from their position
and they still haven't started towing
the trailer
toward and bjorn have just found out
they have a major problem with the truck
they just pulled out of the ditch
plus there's the back trailer that's
still on its side
and they're about to be hammered by a
major storm
the axle is not excellent
so we try to make something so he can
drive easy though
we have to do this as quick as we can
because the weather
will be worse than it is now so
it's a difficult job
[Music]
foreign
after a cherry rigged fix the truck can
be driven down the mountain
but the storm is raging and the trailer
is still in the ditch
i was told that i could drive down to uh
bjorn in 8th floor and leave the truck
behind there and take ordinary car and
drive home
then they're going to fix this big truck
for me
and i'm going back and pick it up when
they are finished
but we have to do it because if we would
leave the truck
we get a whole day of extra work
we have to get a machine to pull away
all the snow
and that's what me and thor talk if we
don't do it
tonight it will be much much more
work to let it stay but then it will be
frozen in the snow
the storm is now getting so fierce that
bjorn orders our camera crew
off the mountain i think it's best that
you
are going down with the other man
driving the truck
follow him and we are staying here it's
too bad better
it's much better that we are here and we
know that you are safe that much better
this is the real mountain in norway
maybe they're coming some animals we can
eat tonight
reindeer yeah you know it sometimes it's
a
animal worked through the storm
and got the trailer down from the
mountain the morning after
maybe we used one and a half hour or
something the trailer was on the road
hard work but it go very nice
[Music]
we don't destroy any things
the trailer was rescued without any
damage to it
or the cargo and the driver is thankful
[Music]
[Music]
as a thank you for their help
[Music]
this driver hits the road again happy
about having his trailer back
drive carefully yeah yep
it's been a long couple of days but the
teams in both the north
and the south can rest easy winter's
finally
here time to make hay while the snow
[Music]
flies
[Music]
you